we are 76 days into the biden presidency
so he's almost done
[Laughter]
yep he's already 70 days longer than we
expected
lots of biden policies and plans to
report on and yet journalists can't stop
talking about you know who i'd love to
hear from both of you how
dc journalists are adjusting to the
biden area this is your first weekend
anchoring here on on saturday and sunday
afternoons do you feel like your rundown
your lineup is is really different than
it would have been in the trump years
when you're asking me if i was run down
i thought you were referring to how i
felt during the trump era
uh no i think that you know listen uh
we're i think we're all dealing with
some post-trump stress disorder
uh you know other than that happy easter
as he was saying in those statements
a few days ago what a bozo yeah these
chuckle buckets
are having a hard time drying out from
the trump era
even though they can call it a day at 4
30 in the afternoon while president
biden's digesting his early bird
tapioca it's almost like they'll find a
trump connection to any news item
out there and one network is cornering
the market
you're watching atn all trump news
because everything else is boring by
comparison
i'm anderson lemon with the headlines
the annual global retirement index is
out with its latest list of the best
places in the world
to spend your golden years topping the
list this year
costa rica followed by panama and mexico
sources say if trump is elected in 2024
we can expect all americans to retire
and move to
literally any country where trump is not
president
and i'll be on the first plane to
bermuda with a suitcase full of edibles
police in georgia say a weekend traffic
jam was caused by a loose cow running
along interstate
285 near atlanta possibly spooked by a
phone call from donald trump
cars were at a standstill for about an
hour until police were able to
safely capture the cow and return it to
its owner
sources say this never would have
happened if donald trump had an
infrastructure plan
that consisted of more than just turning
wayward cattle
into well done steak i swear i
do not know how we ever survived that
guy
and a new study shows that people cannot
tell the difference between screams of
joy
and screams of terror researchers at
emory university say the two types of
screams
have similar acoustics for example if i
attended a sugar ray concert in the 90s
sheer joy
whereas if i attended a trump rally
unmitigated terror
thank god i'll never have to see those
again i mean all those happy people with
the flags and the children and the
grandparents and the ymca
ah makes me sick to my stomach
seriously i think i need to see my
gasterologist
although he voted for trump twice oh god
i hate him
more headlines in 30 minutes i'm
anderson lemon
i am worried about her um
eric what is it
what is it like to know that your dad
has like a really unusual psychological
effect on
people especially in the media it's a
strange unless you
unless you've experienced it yourself oh
trust me i've experienced it myself
by the way to see acosta act like that
it's actually like incredibly refreshing
but it's true guys i mean
can i can i just call it for what it is
i mean biden is boring as hell
yeah kamal is nowhere to be found could
you imagine if i acted
the way that some of the biden kids did
meaning if i took one penny from china
if i took one penny from the ukraine
if i was smoking parmesan cheese yes
i mean he couldn't have got elected
right let's let's just be very honest
about this right
watch what you say about people who
smoke parm cheese oh no not again
can we let that topic go but listen they
can't they can't help themselves it is i
watch seen elena try
right it is all trump all the time they
can't let him go i mean remember
remember how entertaining the press
conferences were back in the day right
and
they're shouting jim acosta the 25th
amendment is he medicated
my father's never had a sip of wine in
his life he's never done any drugs he's
like
is he a medicated person now they have
nothing to talk about they have no one
to rant
and rave their ratings stink you know
twitter's boring
well it's harder because before all they
had to do
was roll a tape and then just sit there
and go wow
wow that's not presidential that's not
having ptsd
like now that that's over they now have
to think
right they now need to think a little
harder it's like it's nothing like ptsd
it's more and it can be tough it's it's
like when you shut your brain off like
you go to bonnaroo
for a couple days and then you're in the
car on the way to the airport on the way
back and you're like can i still read
like kind of like that
which is hard and scary yeah that's when
you think
you think you might have done some kind
of permanent damage because temporarily
you think it's over
yeah right exactly but you can work
through it it's not ptsd it's just you
know you're a little rusty on the
thinking
tires i guess i mean the thing is we're
almost guilty of the same thing because
we're sitting here talking about it too
no but it's different and you guys could
not all be wronger
this has nothing to do with tts
trump just what it's bank disorder ah
every time he i interviewed i got to
write a book about him i was making
money about him yes i was getting
promotions because he picked on me in a
press conference
right he was good for my bottom line
ain't nobody buying a book that didn't
have trump's name on it remember i
wanted to just put a
book out that just said trump trump
trump just 365 pages of trump 1995 is
yours
because that's what's really hurting
they pockets because they can't have
books anymore
they can't get paid for one-on-one
interviews to talk about the time
that he told him he was unfair yeah you
know what i'm saying so this has nothing
to do this is
they're hoping that they will say
something because in the past
if you took a shot at president trump
hit fire a two-piece back at you
and then boom you got a book again and
you wanna
you want everyone's tv show because you
got breaking news president trump
insulting me
roll the tape that's right and then when
they they come back like wow and then
you get a panel of 47 people
to talk about it and then two weeks
later my book trump
terrorized me that's what's going on
anybody buying jim acosta in my day at
workbook
brian shelter's pop-up book like who do
you want to see that oh a pop-up book by
brian stelter think about it what would
be popping up i don't know
at least jeffrey
that pop-up book would be really bad
really bad all right enough of the
pop-up book jokes cat
uh i i i i i disagree i i think they do
suffer from a psychiatric disorder at
cnn um
i've wondered what it was i thought it
was narcissistic personality disorder
i've seen all the symptoms the delusions
of grandeur
the rambling on about imaginary
irrelevance it can also happen at
bonnaroo
yeah this is true but i mean they've
tried they've tried to replace trump
with
joe biden's german shepherd right
they're trying to yes
no they're trying to get us interested
in this it's like
bewitched after they took the first
darren away it's it's a boring show
and and i don't blame them but the
problem is not trump the problem is
when he went away it revealed how sick
in fact they
really were they no longer had somebody
to bounce it off of yeah so you're
saying trump is dick york
and biden is dick sergeant and hunter
bind's just a
yes yeah you didn't see that one coming
do do you have to bleep that i don't
think you have to bleep that because use
it as a name
you can use it as a name okay okay thank
you short for richard richards
there you go